[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend in allen zu einem heute-journal
das nach vorne schaut denn es geht heute
in der Politik um entscheidende
Zukunftsfragen für dieses Land und die
sind auch deshalb so dringend weil in
der Vergangenheit so viel versäumt wurde
und sich gegenwärtig deshalb enorme
Baustellen auftun solche im übertragenen
Sinn und ganz konkrete womit wir bei der
Verkehrspolitik wären immer mehr Autos
und LKW immer Misere Straßen von der
Bahn noch gar nicht zu reden in den
letzten Wochen sind da vor allem
Umweltministerium grün geführt und
Verkehrsministerium FDP geführt heftig
aneinander geraten es gibt viel zu
kitten zu moderieren und zu entscheiden
wenn es voran gehen soll heute im
Koalitionsausschuss Christian hübscher
fast vier Stunden reden sie am Abend im
Kanzleramt Grüne und FDP müssen unter
Aufsicht der SPD eine Schlüsselfrage der
Verkehrspolitik verhandeln die bis an
den Markenkern bei der Parteien rührt im
Grunde geht es darum Deutschlands
Infrastruktur auf lng-tempo zu bringen
wo ein flüssiggasterminal in nur fünf
Monaten möglich war das ist jetzt das
neue deutschlandtempo dass die Ampel
gerne auch anderen Ort hätte im
Koalitionsvertrag heißt es beschleunigt
auf den Weg bringen und mit hoher
politischer Priorität umsetzen wolle man
systemrelevante Bahnstrecken
Stromtrassen kritische Brücken und genau
da beginnt der Streit zwischen grüner
Umweltministerin und FDP
Verkehrsminister denn er will auch neue
Autobahnen beschleunigt bauen ein
spürbar emotionales Thema für Volker
Wissing die Straße ist immerhin noch der
wichtigste Verkehrsträger den wir haben
wer meint dass ignorieren zu können aus
irgendeinem Gefühl heraus der
versündigt sich an den Bedürfnissen
dieser Gesellschaft Steffi Lemke aber
pocht auf den Koal Arbeitsvertrag kein
Vorrang mehr für Straßenbauprojekte wie
aktuell bei Frankfurt 1000 Bäume im
Fechenheimer Wald müssen Weichen für den
Ausbau der A66 und den Bau eines Tunnels
was ich nicht für sinnvoll halte ist in
Zeiten der Klimakrise und des Arten
Aussterbens zu sagen dass der Neubau von
Straßen wichtiger wäre als Klimaschutz
oder auch der Naturschutz eine solche
Achsenverschiebung im Umweltrecht die
hielte ich für falsch auch
umwelt-position das ist
rückwärtsgewandte reaktionäre Politik
zukunftsorientierte Politik baut die
umweltfreundlichen Alternativen aus das
heißt Bus Bahn Fahrrad Fußgängerverkehr
der muss gestärkt werden aber neue
Autobahn müssen wir in Deutschland nicht
mehr bauen am Ende gibt es keine
Interviews keinen Beschluss Papier alle
Beteiligten entwinden kommentarlos in
die Berliner Nacht eine Einigung sieht
wohl anders aus
ja manche zu Fuß manche mit dem Auto wir
haben uns bereits daran gewünscht dass
sie in solchen Koalitionsrunden im
Kanzleramt einerseits die wirklich
wichtigen Richtungsentscheidungen fallen
aber andererseits bis dahin viel
rätselraten herrscht guten Abend Theo
wie sieht's denn heute Abend aus
naja also wenn die Spitzen der Ampel
vier Stunden lang zusammen gesessen
haben und wenn auf dem Tisch ein riesen
Streit Thema lag und mir danach ein
Teilnehmer schreibt dann habe Zitat
konstruktive Gespräche zu Verkehr und
Klimaschutz geführt dann ist ziemlich
klar dass ich dahinter auch weiterhin
massiver politischer Streit verbirgt und
zwar ein Streit über den richtigen Weg
und den richtigen Inhalt also wie viel
Geld wird künftig in den Ausbau der
Schiene gesteckt und wie viele neue
Autobahn morgen haben die beteiligten
Parteien jeweils getrennt ganz früh zu
Hintergrundgesprächen eingeladen dann
werden wir wahrscheinlich
unterschiedliche Versionen desselben
abends hören jetzt ist ja das größte
streitfeld offensichtlich diese
schnelleren Planungsverfahren und das
kann man ja auch nachvollziehen als
Bürger dieses Landes jeder kann er
mittlerweile Projekte aufzählen die zu
Lachnummern geworden sind in Deutschland
wie groß sind denn die Chancen dass sich
daran tatsächlich was ändern wird
ja also diese die Lachnummern die sind
wirklich ja so dass einem das Lachen
immer häufiger im Halse stecken bleibt
eher vor Scham weil die Bauzeit und die
Probleme des Berliner Flughafens hier
zum Beispiel sind ja nur ein extrem
Beispiel das Schneckentempo in den
Abläufen ist natürlich allen in der
Bundesregierung bewusst des spiegelt
sich ja auch zunehmend im
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang Deutschlands
wirtschaftsfeld nicht zuletzt auch
deshalb im internationalen
Wettbewerbsvergleich immer weiter zurück
die Ampel hatte es erkannt hat in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag die sogenannte
planungsbeschleunigung beschlossen
gestritten wird aber natürlich jetzt
darüber ob das auch für den weiteren
Autobahnbau gelten soll und was den
Streit zwischen den Grünen und den
Liberalen verschärft ist es der
Verkehrsbereich insgesamt die Klimaziele
nicht erreicht und das fällt in die
Zuständigkeit des ftp-minister Wissen
Theorie ich würde mal sagen wir werden
da noch weiter darüber reden auch wir
beide hier für heute erstmal herzlichen
Dank nach Berlin danke und auch für
Deutschland Wirtschaft heute ist ein
Blick in die Zukunft der zuständige
Minister fast seinen Bericht dazu so
zusammen die Zahlen sind nicht gut aber
besser als noch vor kurzem erwartet bis
zu zwölf Prozent Wirtschaftseinbruch das
waren im letzten Jahr ja zwischendurch
mal die Vorhersagen mit Blick auf den
Winter hatte sich das Böse R-Wort ins
Gedächtnis und ins Gemüt gebrannt und
jetzt
Rezession das Wort taucht nur ganz klein
gedruckt auf Frank Buchwald hat mehr
Robert Habeck würde so gerne mal tief
durchatmen die Wirtschaftsdaten die der
Minister im Bundestag verkündet sind
zwar nicht ganz so schlimm wie im Herbst
befürchtet Wachstum immerhin 0,2% aber
sind nicht viel die Zahlen die wir
gestern vorgelegt haben im
Jahreswirtschaftsbericht sind nicht gut
aber sie sind bei weitem besser als wir
noch vor wenigen Wochen befürchten
mussten wir haben diese Krise handhabbar
gemacht wir haben den Trend der
Inflation gebrochen Inflation knapp zwei
Prozent weniger was habe ich aber als
Trend umkehrpreis nennt die Opposition
ganz anders das ist die größte
sozialpolitische Aufgabe die es aktuell
in Deutschland gibt denn Inflation das
ist Raub am kleinen Mann und ich hätte
mir gewünscht wenn Sie mehr zu diesem
Thema hier gesagt hätten statt es mit
Trendumkehr gesund zu werden tatsächlich
soll die Inflationsrate von 7,9 % im
letzten Jahr nun auf 6% sinken die
Preise steigen also immer noch nur
langsamer für die allermeisten Menschen
wird das Jahr 2023 bedeuten eine
Inflation eine Entwertung des Geldes die
deutlich über der Lohnsteigerung liegen
wird also die meisten Menschen werden
auch in diesem Jahr den Gürtel enger
schneiden müssen das gilt jedoch nicht
nur für die Bürger auch Unternehmen
erwarten von der Politik nun Entlastung
weniger Bürokratie mehr Tempo so über
den lng-terminals der Kanzler spricht
vom deutschlandtempo wir begrüßen das
sehr aber dafür muss doch noch einiges
getan werden damit verwirklichen
Deutschland Tempo kommen auch wenn der
milde Winter kurzfristig entlastet des
Hauptproblem sind nach wie vor die hohen
Energiepreise und mit Gas aus Russland
rechnen keiner mehr höchstens die
Linkspartei
Putin hat mit seinem verbrecherischen
Angriffskrieg diese Situation verursacht
aber es sind ihre kopflosen
energiesanktionen die die Weltmärkte
erst in dieses Chaos gestürzt haben das
ist leider die Wahrheit das sieht der
austausschuss der deutschen Wirtschaft
völlig anders die abkupplung von
Energielieferungen aus Russland habe
bisher ganz gut funktioniert wenn auch
zu hohen Preisen Russland war ein
wichtiger Partner in ganz vielen
Bereichen werden große Pläne auch bei
der Energie- und klimapartnerschaft aber
unter den jetzigen politischen
Bedingungen ist eine wiederernährung
unmöglich doch auch wenn Deutschland
über den ersten Schock hinweggekommen
ist der gefühlte Stress für die deutsche
Wirtschaft bleibt gewaltig und so muss
Robert Habeck auf das große durchatmen
wohl doch noch eine Weile warten
[Applaus]
habe mir gerade schon kurz gesehen der
Präsident des Deutschen Instituts für
Wirtschaftsforschung ist bei uns Marcel
Fratscher Herr Professor guten Abend
guten Abend ein bisschen wachsen also
statt schrumpfen sagt die Regierung
voraus dreht sich denn da die Stimmung
wirklich nachhaltig in Deutschland
gerade
sie dreht sich aber die Zahlen sind
nicht so gut wie sie klingen zum eher
zum einen wir reden hier über einen
optimistisches Szenario also eine
Stagnation es kann viel schief gehen
Eskalation des Krieges
widersteigende Energiepreise oder auch
Lieferketten Probleme durch
Handelskonflikte also es könnte noch
deutlich schlimmer kommen und zweitens
dürfen wir
Wohlstand nicht mit Wachstum verwechseln
denn es Stagnation der Wirtschaft
verdeckt eben das die Inflation deutlich
über der Lohnsteigerungen sie liegt und
das trifft vor allem Menschen mit
geringen Einkommen Mensch mit geringen
Einkommen haben eine deutlich höhere
Inflation individuell und das bedeutet
gerade Menschen mit mittleren geringen
Einkommen werden dieses Jahr den Gürtel
nochmal deutlich enger schneiden müssen
also wir haben eine zu höchst unsoziale
Krise und das wird sich in diesem Jahr
fortsetzen aber die wirklich
dramatischen
Szenarien also ich sag mal minus 10%
runter
-12% runter die ist im letzten sogar
noch gab die sind ja nicht eingetreten
zum Glück muss man sagen woran lag das
denn dass die nicht eingetreten sind
es sind drei Gründe die die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung besser da
stehen lassen im Augenblick als
befürchtet einmal eine Energiesicherheit
es ist der Bundesregierung gelungen und
das ist ein Erfolg den man anerkennen
muss die gaspeicher zu füllen lng-gas
das haben wir eben auch im Bericht
gehört zu sichern und auch riesige
Wirtschaftshilfen 200 Milliarden Euro an
Hilfen für Unternehmen und auch für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger gibt kaum ein
Land wo größere Hilfen aufgelegt wurden
und als drittes auch die Weltwirtschaft
hat sich stabilisiert China öffnet sich
und das sind die drei Faktoren weshalb
es wirtschaftlich bisher nicht so
schlimm gekommen ist wie befürchtet sie
haben gesagt die normalen Bürger müssen
den Gürtel eher enger schnallen auf der
anderen Seite gab es wirklich
gigantische Wirtschaftshilfen gibt's
immer noch wir erleben jetzt gerade
etwas ganz interessantes an der Börse
nämlich läuft das zunehmend wieder
goldig die Verbände die
Wirtschaftsverbände zeichnen aber
gleichzeitig Schreckenszenarien ruft er
die Wirtschaft auch deshalb immer
besonders laut Alarm weil sie damit
einfacher staatliche Unterstützung
bekommt
ja ja nein also wir muss auch bei der
Wirtschaft natürlich differenziert
betrachten es gibt viele Verlierer
gerade im Mittelstand kleinere mittlere
Unternehmen leiden sehr aber wir sehen
gleichzeitig das große DAX-Konzern
Rekordgewinne einfahren und deshalb eben
auch die Börsenpreise steigen also es
gibt eine Menge unternehmen die konnten
die höheren Kosten weitergeben konnten
ihre Gewinnmargen noch mal erhöhen und
deshalb muss man eben hier sehr
differenziert hinschauen es gibt eine
Menge Verlierer aber es gibt eben auch
eine Reihe von gewinnen auch unter den
netten Unternehmen die von dieser Krise
profitiert haben jetzt haben wir in
dieser Sendung schon häufiger dass eins
der neuen Lieblingsworte des Kanzlers
gehört Deutschland Tempo bislang ist es
eher ein Schlagwort und noch nicht so
richtig mit mit Leben gefüllt worauf
muss es denn jetzt aus ihrer Sicht
ankommen damit dieser leichter
Aufwärtstrend sich versteht
die Politik muss ein Kehrtwende
vollziehen sie muss von einer
Krisenbekämpfung im vergangenen Jahr
jetzt wirklich zur Transformation zur
langfristigen Transformation der
Wirtschaft hin das erfordert gerade im
ökologischen und im digitalen Bereich
eine große Transformation das erfordert
nicht Subvention von fossilen
Energieträgern das wäre der falsche weg
davon muss die Politik wegkommen sondern
bessere Rahmenbedingungen für private
Investitionen Fachkräfte Problem
adressieren schnellere
Genehmigungsverfahren weniger Bürokratie
eine deutlich bessere Infrastruktur beim
digitalen bei dem Verkehr weniger
Regulierung das sind die Prioritäten
damit Unternehmen investieren können
aber nicht eine Politik der Subvention
das wäre der falsche Weg unternehmen
müssen sich erneuern und die
Transformation angehen viel zu tun
Professor Marcel Fratzscher ganz
herzlichen Dank auch heute Abend für das
Gespräch über uns sehr gerne
ja und dann die Zukunft der Bundeswehr
ein neuer E-Book in der Kürzel Liebenden
Armee steht das für Inhaber der befehls-
und Kommando Gewalt ein neuer E-Book
also aber dieselben alten Probleme zu
denen jetzt noch ein gewaltiges neues
kommt Boris Pistorius fährt Panzer heute
bei seinem ersten Truppenbesuch seit er
das schwierige Amt übernommen hat und er
muss jetzt schnell Antworten finden auf
die Frage wie die Bundeswehr die ja
ausrüstungsmäßig sowieso auf dem letzten
Loch pfeift jetzt schnell Ersatz bekommt
für all das was sie an die Ukraine
abgibt und dazu gehören ja mittlerweile
auch 14 Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 Andreas
Weise hat den Minister beim
Logistikbataillon 171 und beim
Panzergrenadierbataillon 122 in
Sachsen-Anhalt beobachtet
nein es ist kein Leopard von dem aus der
neue Bundesverteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius sich anschaut wie ein Gefecht
simuliert wird es ist eine andere
Raubkatze auf Ketten der Puma zuletzt er
durch Ausfälle in den Schlagzeilen heute
gab es keine Probleme trotzdem die
Weitergabe von Waffen und Ausrüstung an
die Ukraine jahrelange Mängel bei der
Beschaffung die Bundeswehr hat viele
Baustellen das weiß auch der Minister
deswegen ist die vorrangige Aufgabe
jetzt für mich mit der Rüstungsindustrie
die Gespräche aufzunehmen und dafür zu
sorgen dass die beschaffungszeiten
deutlich verkürzt werden da wo immer es
geht oder ausgeholfen wird mit Material
was dazu geeignet ist insbesondere beim
Thema Munition kommt natürlich dass die
mengenfrage dazu passieren trotz
Munitionsmangel die Schießübungen hier
auf dem Truppenübungsplatz sind noch
drin
doch der Kommandeur verbindet mit dem
Besuch des Ministers eine Hoffnung
für den Ausbilder wir haben hier seit
Jahren den Mangel verwaltet
und ziel muss es sein wieder an eine
Vollausstattung heranzukommen auf
schnelle Lösungen der Probleme kann die
Bundeswehr aber kaum hoffen
man muss rechnen dass wenn man jetzt was
neues bestellt dass das ungefähr zwei
Jahre dauert und die Zeit kann ich stark
verkürzt werden weil einfach die
Industrie erstmal die Rohmaterialien
besorgen muss die Komponenten besorgen
muss Boris Pistorius will nicht zurück
sondern lieber nach vorne schauen doch
so ganz wird er den Versäumnissen der
Vergangenheit nicht entkommen können der
neuer verteilungsminister fängt nicht
bei Null an sondern bei -10 war bei
minus 100 das heißt also er muss mit den
Fehlern der Vergangenheit erstmal leben
und auf der anderen Seite der
Wiederaufbau ist solche
verteidigungssektors wir ziehen 15 Jahre
dauern einen langfristigen Plan haben
wie man das tatsächlich umsetzen kann
die Lieferung der Leopard Panzer an die
Ukraine ist beschlossene Sache trotzdem
gab es heute kritischen Nachfragen auch
aus dem Ausland
warum hat es so lange mit dieser
Entscheidung gedauert ähm
Highlight lassen Sie mich hervorheben
dass wir nicht gezögert haben ich werde
nicht müde zu wiederholen dass wir nicht
gezögert sondern verhandelt
dem ersten Besuch bei der Truppe heute
in Sachsen-Anhalt sollen viele weitere
folgen die Sorgen Nöte aber auch
Anregungen der Soldatinnen und Soldaten
sein ihm wichtig zu der Minister den
richtigen Ton scheint er zumindest schon
mal gefunden zu haben
und die Menschen in der Ukraine waren
heute wieder Ziel von schweren Angriffen
aus Russland damit beginnst du jetzt
Hannah die Ukraine wurde erneut von
einer massiven Welle russischer Raketen
und Drohnenangriffe getroffen dabei
starben laut zivilschutzdienst
mindestens elf Menschen viele sein
verletzt worden auch in Kiew wurden
Gebäude beschädigt tausende Bewohner
suchten Schutz im U-Bahn-System der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt Angaben des
Militärs konnte ein Großteil der
russischen Geschosse abgefangen werden
im Dezember war ein Mitarbeiter des
Bundesnachrichtendienstes wegen
mutmaßlicher Spionage für Russland
festgenommen worden nun wurde ein
möglicher Komplize gefasst dieser soll
die geheimen Informationen die der
BND-Mitarbeiter ausspionierte nach
Russland gebracht haben das erklärte die
Bundesanwaltschaft er sei der
Mittäterschaft am Landesverrat dringend
verdächtig der Mann ist deutscher
Staatsbürger und kein BND-Mitarbeiter er
sitzt in Untersuchungshaft
in einer internationalen koordinierten
Aktion ist den Behörden in Deutschland
und den USA ein entscheidender Schlag
gegen das hacker-netzwerk half gelungen
wie US-Justizminister Garland in
Washington erklärte soll die Gruppierung
mit mehr als 1.500 schweren
Cyberangriffen Unternehmen und Behörden
erpresst haben über 70 davon in
Deutschland auch das Bundeskriminalamt
und spezialisierte Behörden aus
Baden-Württemberg waren an den
Ermittlungen beteiligt
bei einem israelischen Militäreinsatz im
Flüchtlingslager Genin im Westjordanland
sind 9 Palästinenser getötet und
Dutzende weitere verletzt worden der
Einsatz ist damit einer der tödlichsten
seit Jahren Israel begründet die Razzia
mit einem bevorstehenden Terrorangriff
als Reaktion kündigte die
Palästinensische Autonomiebehörde einen
Stopp ihrer Koordination in
Sicherheitsfragen mit Israel an das
Flüchtlingslager Palästinenser
das müssen furchtbare Szenen gewesen
sein gestern in einem Regionalzug
zwischen Kiel und Hamburg man will sich
das nicht vorstellen müssen und doch
sind jetzt antworten nötig auf wichtige
Fragen auch an unseren Rechtsstaat der
mutmaßliche Täter hatte mehrere
Vorstrafen er ist jetzt in
Untersuchungshaft der Vorwurf zweifacher
Mord und versuchter Totschlag eine
17-Jährige und einen 19-jähriger zwei
junge Leben sind bei der Messerattacke
getötet worden Heike Kruse mit mehr aus
Kiel
weiße Rosen für die Opfer
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer
besucht am Tag nach der messe-attacke
den Bahnhof von Brokstedt zwei Menschen
starben hier gestern im Zug von Kiel
nach Hamburg eine 17-Jährige junge Frau
und ein 19-jähriger Mann drei Menschen
erlitten schwere Verletzungen und zwei
Personen schweben in Lebensgefahr laut
Augenzeugen berichten war der
mutmaßliche Täter mit einem Messer durch
den Zug gegangen und hatte auf Reisende
eingestochen ich saß Einwanderung weiter
und es kam dann drei Mädchen Waggon
gelaufen die nur geschrieben haben hat
Messer ein Messer lauft dann
glücklicherweise gerade den Bahnhof
eingefahren in dem Moment kam der
vermeintliche Messerstecher in unserem
Wagon wollte die Treppe hoch mit der
erhobene Hand und dem Messer und hat
sich ein Mitfahrer dem
entgegengeschmissen bzw den Koffer
entgegengeschmissen der genaue
Tathergang im Zug und auf dem Bahnsteig
ist noch unklar tatverdächtig ist ein
33-jähriger Staatenloser Palästinenser
der 2014 nach Deutschland kam und hier
mehrmals auffällig wurde erst vor einer
Woche war Ibrahim a in Hamburg aus
Untersuchungshaft entlassen worden dort
sah es er wegen eines Messerangriffs auf
einen Mann vor der Essensausgabe einer
Obdachlosenunterkunft die
bundesinnenministerin fordert Aufklärung
wie konnte es sein dass ein solcher
Täter noch hier im Land war wie konnte
das passieren und wie konnte es
passieren dass er trotz so vieler
Vorstrafen nicht länger im in einer
Justizvollzugsanstalt war und wie konnte
es passieren dass er so früh aus
Untersuchungshaft auch wieder entlassen
wurde die Hamburger Justizbehörden
dagegen sprechen von einem ganz normalen
Vorgang streng nach Recht und Gesetz
ich glaube man kann hier nicht von der
vorzeitigen Haft Entlassung sprechen die
Situation ist hier so dass der dass die
Person im August letzten Jahres
verurteilt worden ist zu einer Freiheit
von einem Jahr und einer Woche und sich
eben schon ein Jahr in Untersuchungshaft
befunden hat im Januar diesen Jahres so
dass Sie hier das Landgericht die
Situation hatte dass die Dauer der
Untersuchungshaft praktisch schon das
Höchstmaß der überhaupt zu verwüsenen
Strafe bei einer erreicht hätte und in
so einer Situation ist es einfach
unverhältnismäßig den Haftbefehl länger
aufrecht zu halten die Motive von
Ibrahima für die Messerattacke in Bruch
steht sind noch unklar allein 120
Zugreisende werden als Zeugen vernommen
einen terroristischen Hintergrund halten
die Behörden aber für unwahrscheinlich
aus Fehlern lernen wir hoffentlich auch
die die Deutschlands Schulen in der
corona-pandemie über eine gefühlte
Ewigkeit dicht gemacht hatten sagen
heute das wäre nicht nötig gewesen der
Chef des RKI hat gerade seinen Rücktritt
bekannt gegeben er findet jetzt der
vorhandene Entscheidungsspielraum sei
während der ganzen Pandemie nicht mit
der nötigen Sorgfalt Ruhe und
Sachlichkeit betrachtet worden okay so
richtig klar klingt das immer noch nicht
Lothar wieder sagt aber auch er habe
wahrscheinlich nicht optimal
kommuniziert
es häufen sich die Studien über
Lernlücken psychologische Folgen
vielmehr Nichtschwimmer drei Jahre nach
dem Corona in unser Leben kam lassen wir
die Hauptbetroffenen selbst zu Wort
kommen ein ZDF-Team war über all die
Zeit immer mal wieder am
innerstädtischen Gymnasium Rostock Bernd
Mosebach
ihr erstes halbes corona-jahr hat Nele
hinter sich mit Homeschooling
wechselunterricht und maskenpflicht es
ist August 2020 was sie noch nicht weiß
zwar zweieinhalb weitere corona-jahre
liegen noch vor ihr
genau wir treffen Nele wieder dazu ihre
Mitschülerinnen und ihre Klassenlehrerin
die Pandemie ist Geschichte die
Erinnerung daran noch frisch ich kann
auch nur für mich sprechen wenn ich sage
das ist mir echt nicht gut ging in der
Zeit wo ich selbst Corona hatte aber
auch in der Zeit wo wir Homeoffice
hatten diese sozialen Kontakte haben
einfach gefehlt und sich auszutauschen
als Jugendlicher ist ein wichtiger Teil
des Alltags eigentlich das Alleinsein
ist bei allen hier die stärkste
Erfahrung der letzten drei Jahre dagegen
eher nur lästig das Hin und Her bei den
Maßnahmen Patricia ist zu Beginn der
Pandemie 14
ja schon nervig müssen Abstand halten
und es ziemlich schwer einzuhalten und
manchmal sicher nicht den Sinn dahinter
und zwar am Anfang stand wir auch alle
zusammen und jetzt auf einmal also ein
bisschen komisch einfach im nächsten
Jahr wollen sie Abitur machen beim
Unterricht auf Distanz allerdings ist so
manches an Lehrstoff auf der Strecke
geblieben wie Mathematik das was man ja
nicht abwählen kann der Oberstufe schon
ziemlich schwer weil gerade so so 8 9 10
Klasse das braucht man das Verständnis
für die Oberstufe
Maren sieht die Pandemie für sich auch
als Chance ist schneller selbstständiger
geworden ich habe es als relativ gut
empfunden dadurch dass ich gelernt habe
mich selbst zu organisieren also meine
meine Sachen selbst zu organisieren
selbst organisieren wenn ich aufstehe
wenn ich das mache wenn ich das andere
also für mich war es echt nicht schlecht
knapp 900 Schülerinnen und Schüler
besuchen das Gymnasium das alles in
allem ist gut durch die Krise gekommen
ist hier konnten viele Eltern ihre
Kinder zu Hause unterstützen es gab
Angebote für Förderunterricht und
Ferienkurse Ines Gottwald weiß aber auch
dass ihr und ihrer klasse bis zum Abitur
noch einiges bevorsteht ja also mit viel
Fleiß kann man das sicherlich alles
aufholen aber das ist auch ein riesiger
Berg an
nachhole Stoff der zu bewältigen ist ne
und ich glaube die diese Folgen dieser
ganzen Zeit
werden uns glaube ich noch eine ganze
Weile beschäftigen das ist jetzt nicht
so jetzt brauchen wir keine Masken mehr
aufsetzen und jetzt ist die Pandemie
vorbei drei Jahre Corona eine prägende
Zeit für diese Schülergeneration manche
werden wohl noch lange brauchen um ihre
Erfahrungen zu verarbeiten andere sind
am Ende vielleicht noch etwas schneller
erwachsen geworden
so und bei uns jetzt hier noch mal
Wirtschaft und noch mal du Hannah ja bin
lange Zeit lief es rund für die
Internationalen Tag Krisen das hat
geraumer Zeit macht die Branche mit
massiven Entlassungen Schlagzeilen nun
hat auch Europas größter
Software-Hersteller der DAX-Konzern SAP
angekündigt das rund 3000 Arbeitsplätze
gestrichen werden Frank Bethmann womit
begründet SAP diesen Schritt und wie ist
diese Entwicklung in der tech-branche
insgesamt einzuschätzen na ja im
Gegensatz zur Industrie und
Handelskammer die hier heute Abend zum
Neujahrsempfang geladen hat ist den
meisten heckkonzernen nicht mehr so zum
Feiern zumute und dann macht auch SAP
wie gesagt heute wissen keine Ausnahme
die Jahre des hyperwachstums sind vorbei
wir erinnern uns noch an die Pandemie
jeder wollte Home Office Produkte und
die Branche dachte das geht immer so
weiter erst wurden massenhaft
Mitarbeiter eingestellt nun folgt eine
regelrechte Entlassungswelle wobei sich
das bei SAP vergleicht man die bezahlen
mit den USA noch in Grenzen hält 3.000
Mitarbeiter weltweit davon 200 in
Deutschland SAP Konkurrent Salesforce
trennt sich von mehr als doppelt so
vielen Beschäftigten ganz zu schweigen
von den tech-riesen angefangen bei
Microsoft und ganz vorne beim Job
abbauen mit dabei der Online-Händler
Amazon für die Betroffenen sind das
keine guten Entwicklungen vom SAP
Betriebsrat gibt es auch heftige Kritik
immer man hat der DAX-Konzern dank eines
starken schlussparteits seine
Jahresziele erreicht Analysten sprechen
aber insgesamt von einer überfälligen
gesunden Korrektur insbesondere in den
USA wurde den Tag Giganten eine gewisse
Maßlosigkeit vorgeworfen sie hätten in
den vergangenen zehn Jahren Geld wie die
Rockstars in den 80ern rausgeworfen
heißt es nun also wird auf die
Personalkosten Bremse getreten einiges
los bei dir vielen Dank
tausende brieftträger Paketboten und
andere Beschäftigte der Deutschen Post
haben erneut ihre Arbeit niedergelegt
bei Post blieben heute bundesweit rund
450.000 Pakete liegen und 1,7 Millionen
Briefe erst vergangene Woche hatte es
mehrtägige Warnstreiks gegeben die
Gewerkschaft wäre die fordert 15% mehr
Lohn für rund 160.000 beschäftigte die
Post lehnt dies jedoch ab die dritte
Verhandlungsrunde findet am 8 und 9
Februar statt
die Journalistin gollineartei wird mit
für ihre Arbeit zur Gleichstellung von
Mann und Frau mit dem Marie juchacz
Frauenpreis ausgezeichnet zu Begründung
heißt es atai stehe für glaubwürdigen
und ausgewogenen auslandsjournalismus
insbesondere für die Frauen im Iran sei
arzei eine wichtige Stimme im Kampf für
Demokratie und Gleichberechtigung seit
2022 leitet die in Iran geborene
Journalistin das ZDF-Studio Kairo zuvor
war sie lange für die ARD tätig
ja herzlichen Glückwunsch auch von uns
allen hier an golini die Kollegin
Maybrit Illner wartet jetzt schon auf
sie mit ihren spannenden Gästen und mit
dieser Frage deutsche Panzer gegen
Russland notwendig aber gefährlich
Fragezeichen ganz wichtig ganz wichtig
und gegen 0:30 Uhr gibt's dann die
nächsten Nachrichten heute journal
Update mit Nazan göktem
Abend tschüss tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das Tief Jan hier mit dem
zentralen Mittelmeer das hochbearte über
dem Atlantik und das Tief Michael bei
Island halten Abstand von uns aber
deswegen ist das Wetter bei uns trotzdem
spannend denn es fällt etwas Schnee und
etwas Regen und es bleibt bei
gefährlicher straßenglätter machen sie
sich heute Nacht also auf Glätte gefasst
etwa von der Ostsee bis zur Eifel etwas
Schnee fällt auch hier in Ostbayern und
in Ostsachsen Nordwesten ist dagegen
auch mal klar kalt genug für Glätte ist
es überall bei Tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen +3 und -5 Grad und morgen
liegen die Höchstwerte bei minus zwei
gerade am Alpenrand und fünf Grad am
Niederrhein und das Winterwetter ist
ganz unterschiedlich für die meisten
wird das wieder ein drüber Tag es fällt
etwas Nieselregen oder auch Schnee
Griesel viel wird das nicht sein
höchstens in den Stau Lagen der
Mittelgebirge vielleicht mal einige
wenige Zentimeter ganz anders sie sind
Schleswig-Holstein aus da strahlt die
Sonne bei Nordostwind am Samstag da kann
es dann hier im Vogtland und den Sacks
noch ein bisschen Schneiden der Sonntag
wird ruhig und am Montag ändert sich
alles da kommt ein Sturmtief heran
bringt Schnee Regen Graupelschauer und
auch einzelne Gewitter mit und es wird
deutlich milder und von allen
Großstädten die wir hier in Deutschland
haben wird Hamburg wohl das garstigste
Wetter zum Anfang der kommenden Woche
bekommen mit Gewittern aber eben doch
Temperaturen häufig über fünf Grad damit
wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen Abend